Film Courage: We will go back to your first
feature WILD IN BLUE.
You had made two short films previously, where
did you get the confidence to know that you
could write it and then execute on it.
Matthew Berkowitz, Filmmaker: I just saw it
like I love confidence is really what I have.
I mean you have confidence as a filmmaker
for sure but it’s more like I just had a
vision of what I wanted the movie to feel
like and sound like and the characters to
say and if I was able to articulate that then
I felt confident in my abilities I just think
it came through doing it for me and it’s
also like as a filmmaker you have to own what
you do right?
So if you own your words and you own the material
you are making and you own up to it right?
Then I think with that comes confidence so
you are willing to take the risks and make
the movie you want to make.
It’s scary but you have to be able to have
confidence in order to do that.
Film Courage: Where do you go for screenwriting
guidance?
Do you go to a book?
Do you go to a website?
Matthew: I’ve read Save The Cat, I’ve
read other books and I’ve read a lot of
screenplays.
I think I’ve ready TAXI DRIVER screenplay
like probably 15 times, 20 times.
So you just read screenplays just the same
way you watch movies to see how movies are
done, you read screenplays.
I had a class in college where all you did
was you watched your favorite movies.
You watched like [Alfred] Hitchcock’s films
and he broke down each act and each structure
and you broke down the script and how it corresponds
to the movie and the movie to your script
and so you just keep breaking it down.
You want to see how they shot the scene, how
they covered it.
You watch the movie, you pause it, you look
at it, look at the shot.
Why did the shot go from a dolly to a wide
and why did the wide go to the close-up here
and why is it a down angle pointed up?
Why do the shots exists the way they do on
screen?
Just look at it.
That was my education, I just watched my favorite
films.